ça va du rapace la croix de multiples
souvent des le conseil de classe de
cédric cerf puisqu'il revient un petit
peu sur tout ce qui s'est passé dans
l'émission et il y un petit peu qui a le
mieux plus parler qui a fait 6 qui a
fait ça c'est un génie du pas aulas est
gentil merci beaucoup
non je dis juste qu'ils avaient sur
batterie beaucoup alors on s'est serré
que vous aimez deux choses dans la vie
jouer au tennis et relooké les gens j'en
sais quelque chose plus grâce à vous je
me me ruiner en frais de barbier et
justement j'ai remarqué au fil des neuf
saisons de l'émission que vous aviez un
talent inouï de coiffeur visagiste
papier c'est le barbier
[Musique]
je vendais des catalogues au salon de
coiffure c'est un professionnel de l'as
coteaux lapointe vous ne quittez jamais
votre ceinture d'accessoires que vous
avez offert jean louis david et vous
proposez vos services gratuitement si
votre souffle à tous la touques ce soir
ce que me disait alors jean michel mr a
vite compris pourquoi vous étiez gratuit
[Applaudissements]
votre client le plus fidèle mais qui n'a
toujours pas trouvé son si c'est bien
sûr gilles verdez ça vous va beaucoup de
la barre avec les cheveux longs et là
bas on vous voit presque plus bon là on
arrive au proverbe ouais là on a un gros
gros gros gros souci n'est pas celle
d'eddy mitchell
pierre bachelet alors quand vous coiffer
c'est comme quand vous chantez il n'y a
plus de deuxième degré c'est flagrant
quand vous relooker le fils de pascal le
grand frère
la boîte à neige bonjour jaune on dîne à
l'accueil bonjour oui tu vois toi toi
fais tu es beau tu suis fan de cheveux
tu vas voir je suis un artiste calme
hier
c'est pas mal hein
tu vois sur la tête de m c'est beaucoup
mieux comme ça
le décollage alors pascal le grand frère
et oui vous avez parce qu'on aura un
gros gros dossiers tout à l'heure on a
appris un truc
ouf voilà sur ophélie winter on aura
toutes les infos bien sûr bernard
montiel viendra nous rejoindre et il y
aura également pascal le grand frère y
aura jean luc azoulay aussi qu'il sera
avec nous le producteur des séries ab
puisque on reviendra sur toutes les
descentes aux enfers voilà ces stars qui
ont connu un immense succès ce qu'on
reviendra aussi sur mallaury nataf vous
avez du miel et les abeilles et vous
allez voir l'info sur ophélie winter qui
va sortir
là on va vous montrer la une dans
quelques instants ok alors si l on se
souvient tous de votre tête de suspense
bref vous pour leur fermeté vous comme
ça voilà ça c'est magnifique
voilà mais il ya quelques jours quand
vous a donné la parole à maxime guinea
et que vous êtes rendu compte que vous
n'auriez pas dû
on a découvert votre tête de regrets
voici un nouveau look baba
[Musique]
je vais donner la parole à maxime denis
ya ce l'anniversaire star académie qui
fabrique alors jean-michel n'est plus là
mais c'est le king des fayots c'est acté
mais il veut tellement vous plaire qu'il
tente de faire des vannes comme tout à
l'heure et vous allez voir cette
terrible déception quand ça ne
fonctionne pas il veut tellement faire
de bonnes interventions de la pression
lui fait perdre l'usagé de la bouche
ce sont les nouvelles aventures du petit
jean-michel ils peuvent aller à
le petit jean michel essaye toujours de
faire rire son professeur mais quand ça
ne marche pas il a du mal à cacher sa
déception alors on aura quelques pour
moi ces bibliothèques bibliothèque et
baston mais le petit jean michel et
persévérant jo ratés de masse et voilà
c'est la femme qui a acheté le catalogue
la redoute d'être comme ça quand j'étais
petit short
non c'est willy oui ou non une page sur
deux c'est à colorier le dessin et
coloris ce truc
le petit jean michel est un élève
paresseux alors dire plus de trois mots
sans bafouiller
c'est beaucoup trop fatigante pour lui
ils sont des programmes qui sont
impossibles à faire donc c'est pas faux
il scrute la pêche et ça casse un peu
les préjugés
on sort de là dedans avec le sourire aux
lèvres moi ça va j'ai adoré ce film
c'est bon c'est ça les jeunes vivent
c'est pas moi c'est presque le double
des autres
[Musique]
il a moins de mal quand on lui demande
ce qu'il a mangé ce midi bien ça ça
roule beaucoup à faire il avait la
pression ce jour ah oui c est ne
regardiez je sentais qu'il fallait pas
que je bafouille contribuer va mieux ça
va mal ça donne la parole à ses impôts
nous raconter ce que vous avez comme
hier soir c'est un peu comme abily
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
françois viaud a fait un retour
fracassant ne touche pas à mon poste ce
qui donne beaucoup d'espoir général mais
un problème dans votre lancement
françois viot oui on vous avait dit quoi
un retour fracassant
qui ça françois viot faisait remarquer
qu'elle a revu la casse et ils effraient
non mais il s'est pas encore mis dans le
nouveau rythme de l'émission quaïda
encore habitué au chocolat gates pas
raison hier soir c'était l'acte 14
devant des corps et vous allez voir que
vu la vitesse de ses réflexes la mèche
qui vient de se faire agresser avant
d'aller trop lourde voici tout de suite
vu you man
pour son retour à l'émission françois
viot été accueillis de la plus belle des
manières
mais la 9e à la race et hier on a bien
vu qu'il n'avait pas encore l'expérience
chocolat gay et je tournais pardon
surtout pour un truc c'est pour le
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
allez france oui les aime comme d'hab
c'est le seul gars qui met une demi
heure à comprendre que ça va partir
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
il a gagné sa place je fais partie du
onze de départ
assad n'est pas encore habitué au
chocolat gay c'est sûr alors on est
jeudi le jeudi aux récompenses qui le
tarbes a bien oui celui ou celle qui a
le plus tacler ses collègues pendant la
semaine
je rappelle que cyril hanouna remporté
le trophée douze fois sur 12 chemmam
cette semaine j'ai trouvé un peu plus
bienveillants changeant très bien les
gens qu'il faut aller très gentil ce
thème j'ai peur que valérie benaïm vous
et à moi aussi je pense froide donc
ouais vous y croyez pas moins de
suspense ou sûr et c'est vous le
carnaval j'ai peur que ce soit cette
semaine le 13e trophée du thar baba est
attribué à
j'étais calme et on fait d'être excités
aux deux derniers jours vous êtes trop
partie inopportune jean michel merle à
tulle à bail un écran je regarde la tv
si vous faites là bas je regarde la tv
adacore jambes je vous regarde
merci ça pas alors l'émission c'est pas
très sympa c'est bien ça vous chauffe
déjà pour les prochaines semaines
[Rires]
d'affilée naturisme moi j'ai fait une
fois parce que j'avais oublié mon
maillot on vous a même pour une planche
de surf
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes déjà tu veux faire quelque
chose revers 0 c'est vrai banon et sa
carrière valence est vrai connard c'est
comme si quelqu'un avait pris la liste
de tous mes reins et avec ouais voilà et
c'est trop beau j'en prends moi c'est
pareil il avait pris la 10 de tous les
cauchemars demi-finales sans être
chauvin
ils ont eu moins de temps de préparation
que l'eau friendly mais c'est vrai on en
a parlé mais vous êtes qui mais ça c'est
pas dit pas qu'on ce qu'elle dit j'en ai
connu
elle est peut-être mieux au basket au
thé vous et je vous dise que je vois
plus je me dis vous m'avez manqué
françois vu aussi c'est vrai mais là je
vous ai déjà trop vu l'envergure d'un
aigle royal est elle plus ou moins
grande que celle de rudy est plus grosse
que oui le faucon mais ce que le vrai
qu'on peut stern
[Applaudissements]